Ngoài 2 tháng 12 năm, khoảng 20 năm, công an phường văn biểu, cuu tử giám,
hà nội cho biết đơn vị đang đuí tra vụ tên án sế ra trên phố tôn đức tham,
hà nội khiến 2 người thương vòng.
Chứ đó, sáng cùng ngày khi công nghiên phà giữa nhà số 1 tháng 12 mốt phố tôn đức tham,
một tấm bệ tôn lớn vất ngờ dưới sủ đồng ỏ văn chương, chúng người đi được.
Theo anh nguyễn văn tham, mỗi nhân viên bảo vệ làm việc gần đó,
bụ tên án sế ra vào khoảng cình chính giờ, tấm bệ tôn rất nặng,
khoảng hơn 14 mốt đường được để kéo nặn ra anh tháng kể lại.
Bất đồng, các quan chức đằng xác định bụt tên án kinh anh mở đe ngờ,
bụt mấy mốt tuổi, chú thêm hóa, tử vòng, chỉ đe tê quyền,
3.5 tuổi, chú chia phố tôn đức tham, bị thương.
Hình công an phường đào vấn đề các đơn vị như vụ khóng nghiệp hiện chương,
tư thập chính cứu, làm sói miên nhìn vụ việc.